Transcription: Viji Gowri
Relecteur: eric vautier
Connaissez-vous le concept
de « Man flu », ou grippe masculine ?
Ce concept qui voudrait
que vous, messieurs,
quand vous êtes atteint
d’un petit virus saisonnier,
vous soyez davantage et plus
longtemps malade que nous, mesdames.
Comprendre si cette expression
qui peut sembler un peu désobligeante
vis-à-vis de la gent masculine
a une réalité scientifique,
constitue mon travail depuis
une dizaine d’années maintenant.
Donc, vous l’aurez compris,
je suis chercheur immunologiste.
Aujourd’hui, vous allez comprendre
pourquoi, en effet, messieurs,
vous avez raison de vous plaindre
quand vous avez la grippe.
Comment en est-on venu finalement
à ce que tout un pan entier
de la recherche,
qui implique différentes équipes
à travers le monde,
s’intéresse à comprendre les différences
liées au sexe en immunologie ?
Eh bien, grâce aux données,
grâce aux chiffres,
aux données épidémiologiques
qui montrent que pour la plupart
des maladies infectieuses,
il existe des différences qui font que
les femmes vont éliminer
de manière plus efficace
les virus, les microbes ou les parasites.
Comment peut-on expliquer
ces différences ?
Ces différences peuvent être expliquées
par différents mécanismes.
Mais ce que je voulais
vous illustrer ici, c’est que,
par exemple,
dans l’épidémie de coronavirus,
on s’est aperçu dès le début
que les hommes étaient plus susceptibles
que les femmes.
En effet,
alors que les hommes et les femmes -
vous vous en êtes sûrement rendu compte -
ont été infectés de la même façon
par le virus,
on s’est très très vite rendu compte
que les hommes étaient surreprésentés
dans les services de réanimation
et surtout qu’ils avaient plus de risques
de mourir du coronavirus que les femmes.
Comment peut-on expliquer
ces différences ?
Certainement par des effets multiples
et certainement complexes.
On peut, par exemple, supposer
que le genre va influencer
la façon dont on va lutter
contre une maladie.
Qu’entend-on par genre ?
On entend par genre des concepts
qu’une société juge appropriés
pour un homme et pour une femme.
Donc les hommes et les femmes
auraient des façons différentes
de se nourrir, de consommer de l’alcool,
de consommer des cigarettes,
d’aller chez le médecin,
de faire attention
lorsqu’ils ont un petit rhume, etc.
Donc finalement,
les femmes auraient globalement
une vie plus saine qui ferait
qu’elles se nourriraient mieux,
boiraient moins d’alcool,
iraient plus facilement chez le médecin,
donc lutteraient plus facilement
contre une infection.
Peut-être, mais pas seulement.
En effet, imaginez-vous
que vous soyez un homme
qui habite à Stockholm,
à Johannesburg
ou dans la campagne indienne,
vous avez toujours
trois fois plus de risques
d’avoir une tuberculose que les femmes.
Donc a priori, avec des modes de vie
assez différents.
Et surtout ces différences
liées au sexe dans l’immunité,
elles s’observent dès la petite enfance.
Dès les premiers mois de vie,
on observe que les garçons
sont plus susceptibles
face aux virus, au rhinovirus,
par exemple.
Donc aux laboratoires,
nous, on a choisi d’étudier
les facteurs biologiques liés au sexe.
Comment des facteurs biologiques
peuvent influencer notre immunité.
Qu’entend-on par facteurs biologiques ?
On entend par là des facteurs génétiques
qui diffèrent entre hommes et femmes.
Vous savez que les femmes
ont une paire de chromosomes X
alors que les hommes ont
un chromosome X, un chromosome Y.
Donc, a priori, les facteurs génétiques,
les gènes qui vont s’exprimer
à partir de ces chromosomes
vont être différents.
Ce qui diffère aussi entre homme et femme,
ce sont les hormones sexuelles,
les œstrogènes en grande quantité
chez les femmes
ou la testostérone en grande quantité
chez les hommes.
Nous, en laboratoire, on étudie cela.
On étudie si ces facteurs
génétiques et biologiques
liés au sexe peuvent influencer
notre immunité.
Vous l’aurez compris,
je suis immunologiste.
Je sais qu’avec le coronavirus,
on est tous devenus
un peu par la force immunologistes.
Mais je vais faire 2-3 rappels.
L’immunologie, c’est la science
qui étudie le système immunitaire.
Le système immunitaire,
son rôle,
c’est de garder notre corps intact.
Intact face au cancer,
intact face aux infections
ou intact face
à une transplantation cardiaque,
par exemple.
Le corps va réagir
et va faire tout ce qu’il peut
pour éliminer ce corps étranger.
Il est composé d’organes,
ces ganglions
qu’on nous a fait palper tout à l’heure
et qui augmentent en taille
lorsqu’on a un cancer
ou lorsqu’on a une angine par exemple,
ainsi que des cellules
qui sont en permanence
en train de patrouiller dans notre corps,
qui vont essayer, qui vont lutter
contre les microbes
en détectant le moindre petit microbe
qui va rentrer dans notre organisme.
Lorsqu’on a tout simplement
étudié cette réponse immunitaire,
elle était différente
entre les hommes et les femmes.
On s’est aperçu que les femmes
développaient des réponses immunitaires
plus fortes et de meilleure
qualité que les hommes.
Ça, ça permettait entre autres,
d’expliquer pourquoi les femmes
luttaient plus efficacement que les hommes
contre les cancers, mais aussi
contre les maladies infectieuses.
En revanche,
cette forte réponse immunitaire,
elle a un coût très important
chez les femmes.
C’est-à-dire que les femmes
développent des maladies
liées à l’hyper activation
du système immunitaire
de manière beaucoup plus
importante que les hommes.
Qu’entend-on par hyperactivation
du système immunitaire ?
Vous avez sûrement entendu parler
des allergies
où le système immunitaire
va se mettre à réagir
contre une substance
qui est a priori inoffensive,
un pollen par exemple
ou un constituant de l’alimentation.
On peut aussi parler
des maladies auto-immunes :
notre corps va se mettre à réagir contre
des constituants de notre propre corps,
notre constitution du soi.
C’est le cas de la sclérose en plaques
dont vous avez sûrement entendu parler,
où notre système immunitaire va s’attaquer
à la gaine de myéline,
ou par exemple
dans la maladie de Hashimoto
où notre système immunitaire
va détruire notre thyroïde.
On s’aperçoit,
comme vous le voyez ici listé,
que pour les maladies auto-immunes
les plus communes,
la plupart des patients
sont des patientes.
C’est-à-dire qu’il y a des maladies
auto-immunes qui sont
préférentiellement et
de manière prédominante féminines.
Donc il est important
de comprendre pourquoi
il y a des maladies qui
sont essentiellement féminines.
Et donc on a essayé de comprendre,
en particulier au laboratoire,
le rôle des hormones sexuelles.
On s’est intéressé
à discriminer le rôle à la fois
des hormones sexuelles féminines,
les œstrogènes,
et le rôle
des hormones sexuelles masculines,
la testostérone,
sur le système immunitaire.
Et on a pu montrer qu’au même titre
que ces hormones sont capables
de réguler la croissance
des organes sexuels secondaires,
par exemple du sein chez la femme
ou des testicules chez l’homme,
ces hormones sont de la même façon
capables de réguler directement
les fonctions et le développement
des cellules du système immunitaire.
Pas toutes les cellules
du système immunitaire,
mais uniquement certains types.
On commence à comprendre
aujourd’hui ces choses-là
et il y a plusieurs équipes
qui identifient plus précisément
quelles sont les cibles de ces hormones.
Il en ressort que globalement,
les œstrogènes,
qui sont les hormones sexuelles féminines,
vont jouer un rôle pro-inflammatoire.
Ces œstrogènes vont booster l’immunité.
Je suis désolée de vous
le dire, messieurs,
mais la testostérone
a un rôle anti-inflammatoire
et donc globalement,
va diminuer la capacité
de votre système immunitaire,
en particulier
à lutter contre une infection.
Au laboratoire, dernièrement,
on s’est intéressé
à une maladie particulière,
l’asthme allergique.
L’asthme allergique,
c’est une pathologie qui est intéressante
parce que c’est une pathologie
dont la susceptibilité,
la différence entre hommes et femmes,
va varier au cours de l’âge
comme vous le voyez sur ce graphique.
On se rend compte que
dans la petite enfance, avant la puberté,
les garçons sont plus susceptibles
que les petites filles
de développer un asthme allergique.
En revanche, après la puberté,
il y a une nette amélioration
de la maladie chez l’homme,
alors que chez les femmes,
il y a une augmentation de la prévalence
de l’asthme allergique.
On a essayé de comprendre
quels pouvaient être les mécanismes
qui régulaient cet asthme allergique
et du fait de ce switch
de la pathologie autour de la puberté.
On s’est intéressé à l’implication
des hormones sexuelles
qui sont produites en grande
quantité à l'adolescence.
Et après de multiples hypothèses
et de multiples expériences,
on s’est rendu compte que
la testostérone, les androgènes,
étaient capables de directement
inhiber chez l’homme
une population de cellules immunitaires
qui est localisée au niveau des poumons.
Le rôle de cette population,
c’est de détecter directement
lorsqu’il y a un allergène qui va rentrer
en contact avec le poumon
et de déclencher cet asthme allergique.
On a pu montrer de manière directe
que la testostérone allait limiter
directement cette population-là.
Donc la testostérone, en empêchant
l’activation de cette population,
empêchait le développement
de l’asthme allergique.
Plus récemment, vous avez entendu parler
de cette pandémie de coronavirus
et on a pu montrer que les femmes
luttaient de manière
beaucoup plus efficace
que les hommes contre cette infection.
Du coup, au laboratoire,
avec d’autres équipes du monde,
on a voulu comprendre pourquoi.
On s’est intéressé à une
population cellulaire qui est clé
dans l’élimination du virus
parce que son rôle,
c’est de produire des quantités
monstrueuses d’interféron.
L’interféron, c’est la molécule
qui permet d’éliminer les virus.
Eh bien, lorsqu’on a étudié
si des facteurs biologiques liés au sexe
étaient capables de réguler
cette population cellulaire,
on a pu montrer que non seulement
les œstrogènes favorisaient
la production de l’interféron
par ces cellules
mais aussi les facteurs génétiques
liés au chromosome X.
On a pu identifier dans l’équipe, un gène
qui était spécifiquement surexprimé
par les femmes
et qui contrôlait directement
l’activation de ces cellules.
Donc chez les femmes,
non seulement les œstrogènes
mais aussi des facteurs
liés au chromosome X,
vont permettre la production
hyper importante d’interféron
et donc l’élimination des virus.
Donc on commence à identifier
les mécanismes
qui sous-tendent
ces différences liées au sexe
et qui expliquent cette meilleure réponse
immunitaire chez les femmes.
Aujourd’hui,
je vous ai parlé d’immunologie,
mais j’aurais pu aussi
vous parler de cardiologie.
On sait que l’infarctus du myocarde
se manifeste différemment
chez les hommes et chez les femmes.
Ou de la migraine encore,
qui est une maladie
qui est essentiellement féminine.
Il est essentiel de comprendre
pourquoi certaines pathologies
se développent
principalement chez les femmes
ou chez les hommes.
Et de manière assez intéressante,
je vais dire,
l’inclusion des femmes dans
les essais cliniques et thérapeutiques,
vous savez, ces essais dans lesquels
on teste les nouveaux médicaments,
n’a été rendu obligatoire
que dans les années 1990
et encore plus tardivement
dans la recherche.
Donc si on veut aujourd’hui
traiter et soigner
de manière similaire
les hommes et les femmes,
il est crucial de comprendre
si une maladie se développe, se déclenche,
progresse ou se traite différemment
chez les hommes et chez les femmes.
Donc vous voyez,
l’innovation c’est aussi parfois
regarder des données, des résultats
avec un œil nouveau.
Finalement, en réévaluant
des concepts aussi simples, que :
est-ce que la santé, c’est similaire
chez les hommes et chez les femmes ?
Il semble en l’occurrence qu’en médecine,
le sexe a de l’importance.
Merci.